we resume with a told by gregory wilson
are from exciting symmetric circus good
afternoon so I'm going to talk about
extending symmetric circuits so that
means I'm to talk about extending work
by Anderson into our and their work on
symmetric circuits and capturing
facebook very importantly um my works
gonna not only extend their work but my
talks actually getting extend that
extend Matt's talk so Matt Anderson this
today spoke about symmetric circuits and
I mean I very crucially rely on his
introduction because otherwise I don't
have anywhere near enough time anyways
oh and also I'm told that the first
results of the election will come out
between now and the end of this talk so
I don't if anyone has asked a question
that encodes information about that I'll
be great anyways so the torque
structured in into three parts first
time's going to quickly discuss some
background on the actual problem of
capturing polynomial time for logic just
that I can justify the introduction sort
of candidate logics and we talked about
Anderson into eyes symmetric circuits
and their attempts to comes down that
problem and then I will talk about how
anusha I have sort of worked on
extensions to the circuit model to try
to see what we
so there's this very central problem in
probably the central problem in just
descriptive complexity of trying to find
characterizations for polynomial x and
capturing capturing problems of
capturing polynomial time and the sort
of first big result in this was by a
moment of already the sort of very
famous theorem that an ordered structure
is fixed points of Isis but of course
fixed point fails hopelessly when you
try to expand past ordered structures
you can't even do things basic things
like parody so in response everyone
conjecture what perhaps fixed point with
counting might work solve this sort of
counting problem directly and the result
was fixed point with counting quite
studied and turned out to be this really
great logic which captured an awful lot
of what we think of as Paul tone real
time what we think this will obviously
polynomial time so it expressed sort of
very obvious however we all packed with
tight problems that will complete a peak
completes or things like the circuit
value problem and sort of far less
trivially it contains things like
maximum matching proved by absent one
home quite recently that's the other end
it also has been used it as the other
answer oh it's also been used that for
capturing results or partial captioners
also in polynomial time so things like
capturing polynomial time of a
particular grass glock graph classes so
pretty the biggest result in this first
bike ride 2010 that works on any proper
minded closed class graphs unfortunately
however fortunately or unfortunately FP
fec turns out not to do the whole of p
time so the cfi query by Khafre
timmerman acts as a kind example
something trivial maturity something
computable in the polynomial time but
not expressible in FPC and later work by
its variants but a thousand a while i
showed that natural fact there's a
rather deep connection between these cfi
queries and they really are plural other
the initial one was constructed it turns
out that you can really find a family of
see if I queries but anyway they define
they show that there's really an
intimate connection between these
problems of you see if I graphs
and solving systems of linear equations
of a finite fields matter of fact they
extended to the solutions of a groups
and rings another algebra in any event
this leads on to this problem of trying
to find what I called candidate logics
in polynomial time that is the state
logic strictly more powerful than FPC
but yet not known to contain the whole
of Palma meal time yet the end goal
being finding when they characterize the
whole polynomial time the first and
really interesting one is called choices
polynomial time whether by blogger [ __ ]
and Sherlock in 999 and it's defined in
terms of what are called bjs machines
now going at the detail but what a bjs
machine we take a long time but the
basic idea is this the Turing machine
takes in an encoding of the structure
and in doing so it sort of implicitly
orders it and what we really like to do
is study what computation looks like on
sort of pure structures so there bgs
machine takes in a direct directly takes
it appears like an unordered structure
it operates on her HD finite sets over
that structure and has access to
parallelism but very very importantly
can't make sort of arbitrary choices so
in some sense it can't make choices
which violate the symmetries of the
input structure and cpt choices
polynomial time is then exactly what
you'd expect it's pgs machines but with
polynomial bounds imposed it's not too
they should I think in the original
paper or perhaps a paper just after that
cpt contains fixed part with counting
and can compute the cfi query so it is
strictly more powerful than a PC an
actual fact that can compute the see if
I query even if you take cbt and without
its ability to count so it's really
powerful it's not known at the moment
whether it can do near equations that
solve systems of linear equations but
more on that later anyways the next
logic that was considered was radtke
logic which the far more direct attack
it takes systems of linear equations
throws in something to solve that
problem so it was proposed originally by
doir al and in 2009 that there was a
slight complication so in the end in
their paper rank logic is dead long live
rank logic
grade Olympic who's a slightly tweaked
it and when I refer to write classic I
refer to their version anyways ranked
logic just takes a fixed point with
fixed point logic with counting and
throws in this rank quantifier which
computes the which takes in a formula
which defines a matrix and some prime
and computes the rank of the matrix in
the in the field of characteristic p and
obviously it can solve systems within
your equations and you can also deal
with the reduction so therefore it can
deal with GFI queries okay so we end up
with something that looks pretty much
like this strict containments I've
explained and the containment inside p
time how to prove the interesting thing
is simply this metal bit we have
absolutely almost no idea where the real
connection between fixed my gaze and cbt
anyways so the next thing I'm gonna talk
about a little bit is the circuit model
that Addison and devar introduced so I'm
going to rely heavily on Matt's talk and
assume those people here went to match
torque and I'm pretty comfortable with
that so essentially they introduce these
circuits they choose a particular basis
and usually the ordinary basis and or
not or else that with some majority
gates and they simply have input gates
so for the moment suppose that we're
taking in a graph will simply have gates
for every potential edge in the graph a
couple of constant gates then we have a
collection of the internal gates which
are labeled with elements from our basis
a boolean basis and then we have just an
output gate so mad also define the
notion of an automorphism of the circuit
so exactly what you expect a struct
preserving map on the circuit from the
circuit to itself and importantly
aniston two are dealt with two
properties or circuits the first being
invariance so in other words the circuit
computes an actual graph property the
second being symmetry which is the
interesting one the idea being that in
this case every permutation of the of
the input and particular these or if the
input gates should induce a permutation
sorry should extend it to a permutation
on the extent to an autumn ilysm on the
entire circuit and an actual fact they
proved that this property is decided by
any property that's decided by people
from families and symmetric circuits is
in fact expressed in FBC so these two
notions our equipment initially they
actually attempted to capture the whole
of problem the whole of cpt but ended up
with this result it was I need to
quickly go over the at a very high level
go how their proof of structured simply
because we're going to make use of it a
little later so I think Matt went
through it in in a fur ball in a lot
more detail so I'll be referencing his
talk here as well so the easy Direction
is taking FPC formulas producing
symmetric circuits in that case you just
do the ordinary shrink existential
quantifiers become large disjunctions
Universal quantifiers large conjunctions
and you can deal with FP as well the
hard direction is going in Reverse
taking symmetric circuits in producing
11 families of symmetric circuits and
reducing FAC columns
so in that case the real powerful
ingredient is this notion of a support
and the support theorem so they take a
support is simply some set s over let's
let's say the inputs are labeled 1 to N
and we're thinking of input structures
as being structures of the universe from
1 to N and support is just something
it's just a set such that every every
permutation that fixes that said
pointwise fixes the the what more for
something at nota morphism extended from
that permutation fixes the gate g and
their proof is structured as follows
they prove that for gates that have
constant size support prove that so long
as the circuit family is P uniform
you're going to end up this P informant
symmetric in end up in a situation where
every gate has constant size supports
and then in parts two and three they
essentially while they use that notion
of constants I support to include all
the information they're going to need to
evaluate the evaluated gate for any
particular permutation the graph and and
they use that and fixed point operator
to actually construct an FPC formula
equivalent to the family of circuits
well the point I really like to
emphasize in this slide is just that
first point proved all gates in the
circuit have small constant size support
smaller constant size board that's the
actual important ingredient here and
that's the bit I'm going after Reverend
Smith later okay so we have this notion
of a symmetric circuit that an assembled
you are introduced but the real trick is
actually now trying to extend that
notion so that we get something more
useful so we have that they capture FPC
perhaps we can try and extend it in such
a ways to capture cpt or perhaps even
rank and we're going to look at two
rather straightforward ways of extending
the notion of a symmetric circuit so the
first way is you you might just might
just take the cemetery condition and
weaken it so an obvious way of doing
that might be well the requirement is
that for every permutation on the input
you have an extended autumn overs and
perhaps you limit that only a few
preparations then you put another
approaches you simply change the basis
take the basis of functions you're
allowed it you allow gate to compute
take the functions you allow gate to
compute
and something more powerful so the first
part we looked at was was weakening
symmetry for a moment let's just take a
step back and think about the
relationship between symmetric circuits
some sort of the ordinary non symmetric
variety so suppose we have a family of P
uniform invariant boolean circuits that
recognize some crap Lisa tiny
environment variable in circuits we
could symmetrized them in quite a
straightforward way so we could imagine
taking every gate and sort of throwing
in the orbit of that gate so let's let's
suppose the gate was connected to the
input the input gate 11 we could take
all permutations of that and simply just
throw in copies of this gate at the
appropriate places so sort of add in the
orbit so we can take a family of
circuits and symmetries everyone and
clearly if that family was still
polynomial then we'd have some it met
that our original circuit was just
computing something at FBC anyways
perhaps we can change that so our
approach was perhaps we can actually
take that family instead of throwing in
the whole orbit throw in some partial
bit and in particular would like to do
is we'd like to sort of take inspiration
from cbt from choices polynomial time
and the bgs machine where the symmetry
isn't for any structure of input n the
symmetry requirement and cpt is really a
cemetery requirement for a particular
input structure so we'd like some input
structure aware symmetry requirement and
see if that can perhaps extend the power
of these symmetric circuits try and
formalize that so suppose we have a
structure a of size n and particular
let's for simplicity to suppose the
structure is over the universe 1 to M so
that makes encoding it into the graph
really straightforward I have to worry
about decoding individual elements so
let's take the encoding avail the sex we
could to be the set of all encodings of
the structure and answered every
possible way of every isomorphic a copy
of a inside that said oh it's sorry
every item of a copy of a with the same
universe
now let's think about all permutations
sorry all permutations of the input
which which for a particular structure a
and a particular gate g keep g constant
for all isomorphic copies of our
structure a
I wouldn't call that the invariance
group of g with respect a any idea here
is that this invariance group or taking
a ticking and the index of this
invariance group and the symmetric group
is going to be a bit like taking the the
index of the orbit and that I sorry the
stabilizer in the symmetric group so
it's going to be something reminiscent
of the orbit but this time with
reference to some structure and
similarly we're going to pound these for
every structure we're going to bound
this orbit notion by some polynomial so
here we for any arbitrary p uniform
family circa family and a polynomial p
we want that for every structure this
sort of the order of this invariance
group of g with respect to a in the
symmetric group is bounded by a
polynomial and we thought this would
really work we thought this was a much
more powerful notion but it turns out
that this family of circuits going to
see if I queer either whether they're
proving that it's it certainly doesn't
capture cbt but it may or may not be a
more powerful model we have this cool
check let's look at the other approach
their approach of expanding the basis
which are actually computing over in
this case let's just start with a rather
obvious observation Addison and doireann
their characterization essentially
proved that symmetric circuits with
majority are much more powerful as
metric circuits without one can think of
it a bit like the situation with the
constant constant depth founded
polynomial size circuits in the ordinary
billion case in that case throwing it
parody gates makes them provably
stronger but we might want to do if we
got to think about adding and functions
is first ask well what functions might
actually improve the power of the model
and it turns out if we are considering
symmetric functions adding in symmetric
functions to the boolean basis does
nothing in a dense metric functions you
like so long as input majority functions
so loose you've got which already gates
you can't you're not increasing the
power of the model at all I should stop
here for a sec and say I'm talking about
symmetric circuits and
and symmetric functions and of course
they're entirely different oceans right
symmetric functions are functions where
any arbitrary permutation on the input
the function has to remain constant in
other words the functionary depends the
number of ones in the input and
symmetric circuits or the tight
different notion I'm I'd love to use two
different words here but unfortunately
it says however when it says them so it
might read a slightly confusing way
anyway so it turns out that some funny
family of the circuits of a subset of
symmetric functions you can find an
equivalent family of circuits with only
a polynomial size blow up with a
standard basis of majority and the proof
approaches is reasonably straightforward
the only slightly tricky thing you have
to think about is the fact that you have
to make sure everything's implemented
symmetrically so perhaps we should look
at something we should look at adding
functions the basis that are less than
symmetric so aren't actually symmetric
functions but are perhaps actually
something symmetric and of course we're
actually thinking either side about rank
logic so we considered adding matrix
symmetric functions in this case an
input is structured with some the input
is structured as a matrix and instead of
requiring that the function is constant
over any arbitrary permutation at the
input we say the function has be
constant for any permutation of the
columns and rows separately was the
obvious example of a matrix metric
companies around function and what ends
up happening is what we end up doing is
we end up doing was proving a support
theorem for the symmetric circuits with
matrix metric gates so take the audit of
the ordinary basis throw in these
additional or allow these additional
matrix symmetric gates on top of
symmetric functions and an actual fact
we can prove that in the event that the
circuit is what this is going to imply
immediately that in the event that the
circuit is P uniform you're going to get
in the viewer in a situation where every
circuit every element the circuit has a
constant size support and by plugging
that into the proof that we mentioned
earlier when that are being able to
prove there's
that that p or form family symmetric
circuits with rank operators are in fact
the same as fixed price right i should
say that shouldn't say just any complete
base a I let's just take the ordinary
basis for member to add or not so the
bit that so let me just quickly conclude
and some of what we talked about what I
talked about so we have this problem
with P time and I sh and from this
problem of capturing polynomial time we
end up with two really interesting
logics to to study CPT and rank logic
and Anderson and wanted to study these
logics a particular cpt in end up dead
but developing this notion of the
symmetric circuit but it fell short of
capturing cbt we studied methods of
trying to extend a rank logic and ended
up showing that some natural extensions
which we thought my capture cbt fail but
that there's an extension of symmetric
circuits which does capture fixed point
with ranked by interesting anyways so I
think it gets definitional what precise
gates do you throw in any any kind of
nonspecific symmetric gate yeah so any
kinds of metrics motorcades well so for
the support theory me throwing kind of
matrix metric aid of course when you're
concretely going to the rest of it you
throw in a ranking there's a slight
trickiness and that you really have to
actually change the notion so I mean
it's it's more complicated than that you
really have to go through and change
your definition of the circuit to
actually allow you two ought to enable
the inputs there's slight subtleties
there but yeah matrix symmetric gates
no matter which kind of matrix symmetric
gates is throw-in you always get back
you know so in the case of the support
theorem when i'm all i'm showing is if
you throw in any symmetric aids you're
still going to get small supports but
then of course when you go through the
rest of the proof you actually have to
be very specific about what you throw
again just for rank a sort of me there
are other kinds of yeah so that would be
very internet with you or whatever and
so we haven't explored what would happen
if you threw in other gates and what it
would look like in particular what would
really like is I mean so we have this
notion that in the cases in a case of
symmetric gates you have this like sort
of complete notion of the majority gate
once you have a majority get you put all
the symmetric aids so a question would
be like well what's the equivalent
notion for a matrix metra gate is there
like some gate you can throw it and once
you've got that you for all the matrix
metra gates and I think in New Jersey
mark of a proof is that so yeah just a
couple so the the support theorem is
proved for any matrix symmetric gate and
then you use that to show that if you
only use rank feeds you can translate it
to write logic and so the question is is
ranked it's enough to do all matrix
symmetric gates and I have an argument
that if that were true that fits quite
where I could wallow p time but the
permanent too right sorry you could also
do the permanent
let's say polynomial time matrix
symmetric it's either in itself yeah but
they winter of these problems then I
mean nobody released a brand logic a
polynomial time again and I mean the
question ranks is not to be helpful for
solving a linear equations is more rings
for instance which are also no idea
there is no reasonable notion of rank /
rings that would be paranormal and
computable and or help to solve linear
equation systems so this is very
unlikely but questions maybe we're sorry
said it's a uniform kind of theorem that
would not just rank logical philosopher
ends I mean I think group membership
cavitation groups is it is an
interesting no no that's but but that I
think this this does address in the
sense that because the support serum
works for any matrix symmetric thing
that means that pretty much for any
matrix symmetric operator you added to
the fixed point logic and you added to
the circuits and you should still get
the equivalent so you get that that
should that kind of thing should work
but ok ok great stuff but I mean the
support theorem definitely works fine
right the rest of it I'd have to make
sure that it actually goes through the
rest
any other questions or answers to yeah
answers the questions we good to you ah
crystal ma'am okay okay so let's